how's it going everyone and welcome to
anyway I am back in Italy with my
girlfriend a lot of you thought that she
was Swedish but no she's the Italians
and that's why I'm here
so I'm still uploading fail frame and
that Island yes more heart is doing it
for me so you're probably not missing me
too much I think but anyway let's get
straight to business because I don't
have a lot of time yes last week last
episode of Friday surprise I I said that
I was good you know the competition you
know want to know who won the
competition right you want to know there
were like 800 something-something
submissions I did not expect so many
people that was like like after after
the first 30 minutes I saw how many
people had already written like shake
all this but I did I did I could shake
gods all of them and they're worse a lot
of a lot of cool channels that I liked
but I narrowed it down to two
so I don't know I hope if you're
submitting like oh you should join my
channel she's gonna like me I didn't
need to hear what I just said I don't
even know what I said but I hope you
don't get like oh he doesn't like me I
like a lot of a lot of channels like if
you had good stuff I probably liked you
but I I wanted to narrow it down to two
so anyway the first winner I really wish
I had more time to edit like explosions
and stuff like that that reminded me a
wheezy waiter anyway um explosion that
was a really bad coffee okay anyway the
first one that I liked was Glee me games
I'll leave her link in the description
subscribe subscribe to her she was
really funny and I don't know there was
just something about it that I really
liked
it was good let's play it's just it's
pretty much what I want I wanted to find
someone that was just generally
enjoyable let's play and yeah just watch
her videos you like them definitely so
go check her out links in the
description and the second one I like I
all actually I'm surprised he's
submitted because I've been boxing him I
really like him Lukey newts man I have
no idea where he's from because he have
a pretty weird surname but goes this guy
see Luke news12 he's really funny and he
swears even more than I do and I really
enjoyed his let's play of that super me
and so yeah I definitely think you
should subscribe to those two people um
I think that was pretty much and I'll
see you and next week